NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
MATT CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA
AGUIAR CURRY.
ALLEN
ARAMBULA
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROUGH.
BURKE
CABALLERO.
CALDERON CARILLO SERVAN TAZ CHAU
CHAVEZ CHEN. DAVID CHIU CHOI
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DAHLE. DALY.
EGGMAN FLORA FONG
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GRAY. GRAYSON
HARPER HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER
KALRA.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMON.
LOW. MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MERCY. NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA.
RAY. RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO STEINORTH STONE.
THURMOND
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER. WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR.
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR TODAY'S
INVOCATION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION TODAY'S
INVOCATION WILL BE OFFERED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHIRLEY WEBER
DOCTOR WEBER.
THEIR FATHER.
WE'VE COME AGAIN TO THANK YOU
FOR THIS AMAZING OPPORTUNITY.
TO REPRESENT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AS LEGISLATORS.
OUR TASK IS TO GIVE VOICE TO THE
MUTE.
SIGHT TO THE BLIND. AND PRESENTS
TO THE INVISIBLE.
TODAY WE ALSO HAVE THE UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO CELEBRATE WOMEN
OF THE STATE.
EIGHTY AMAZING WOMEN.
WHO STRONG SERVICE HAS MADE THIS
STATE IN THIS NATION GREAT?
FATHER MUCH HAS BEEN WRITTEN BY
HISTORIANS AND PHILOSOPHERS AND
POETS ABOUT THE POWER AND
INFLUENCE OF STRONG WOMEN.
THEIR PRECIOUS AS RUBIES.
THEY CAN MAKE A WAY OUT OF NO
WAY.
AS THE FIRST TEACHER THEIR HAND
ROCKS THE CRADLE AND SHAPES AND
RULE THE WORLD.
AFRICAN PROVERB SAFE WHEN YOU
EDUCATE JUST ONE OF THESE WOMEN.
YOU EDUCATE THE ENTIRE VILLAGE.
THE COURAGE AND STRENGTH.
CLIMBING LADDERS WOULD BROKEN
ROUNDS AND SHATTERING GLASS AND
STEEL CEILING SPEAK OF THEIR
STRENGTH.
AND THEIR PERSISTENCE.
SO TODAY WE HONOR THESE WOMEN
WHO OUR SISTERS OUR MOTHERS ARE
ANTS ARE ROLE MODELS ARE BEST
FRIENDS AND ARMY.
YET DOING THIS MOMENT OF
TREMENDOUS CELEBRATION.
WE WOULD BE REMISS.
IF WE DID NOT RECOGNIZE THE
CHALLENGES FACED BY THE STATE
AND NATION REGARDING THE
TREATMENT OF WOMEN.
WELL WE HAVE PASSED
GROUNDBREAKING LEGISLATION TO
PROVIDE EQUAL PAY AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR WOMEN AND GIRLS.
WE'LL STILL HAUNTED BY THE
TRADITIONAL INSTITUTIONAL
CHALLENGES OF SEXISM AND
HARASSMENT.
BUT SEEK TO OBJECTIFY WOMEN
ACROSS THE STATE IN THIS NATION.
NO CORNER OF THIS NATION.
NOT EVEN THIS HOUSE
HAS EXPECT THE PUTRID SMELL OF
THIS UGLINESS.
IF THESE WOMEN.
LIKE THEIR FOR MOTHERS.
PERSIST IN SPITE OF THIS
REALITY.
MANY HAVE FACED THE UGLY
MOUNTAINS OF ARRESTS MIGHT
DISGRACE IN DESPAIR. AND THAT'S
YOU OUT OF THAT MOUNTAIN AYE
STONE OF STRENGTH.
BEAUTY BRILLIANCE AND
RESILIENCY.
WITH AND WITHOUT A HASH TAG.
THESE WOMENHAVE PERSISTENCE TO
BUILD BRIDGES OVER TROUBLED
WATERS.
THEY HAVE BEEN STANDING IN THE
GAPS OF POVERTY AN OPPORTUNITY.
THEY HAVE NEVER GIVEN UP.
NEVER GIVEN IN.
AND NEVER GIVEN OUT.
AND FOR GENERATIONS
THEY HAVE SAID ENOUGH.
WHEN FACED WITH BIGOTRY SEXISM
AND DISCRIMINATION.
THEY ARE THE PROVERBIAL VIRTUOUS
WOMAN.
THERE ALICE WALKER'S TREES
PLANTED BY RIVERS OF WATERS THAT
CANNOT BE MOVED.
THEY ARE THE CHINESE PROVERBS
WOMEN WHO HOLD UP HALF THE SKY.
AND THROUGH IT ALL.
AS MARI EVANS SAYS THEY REMAIN
ASSAILED.
IMPERVIOUS AND THEY ARE
INDESTRUCTIBLE.
FATHER TODAY WE NOT ONLY
CELEBRATE THESE WOMEN AND THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS.
BUT ON BEHALF OF THE STATE. WE
SAY WITHOUT RESERVATION. WITHOUT
HESITATION AND SINCERE GRATITUDE
FOR ALL OF THEIR HARD WORK.
WE COLLECTIVELY SAY.
THANK YOU.
LET THE PEOPLE WHO AGREE SAY A
MAN.
THANK YOU THAT WAS POWERFUL.
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SABRINA CERVANTES OF THE
SIXTIETH FIFTH DISTRICT.
SHE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE.
CERVANTES.
PLEASE FOLLOW AFTER ME I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
BOB.
IT IS ABLE.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
WE MOVE TO THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER SACRAMENTO THURSDAY
MARCH FIRST TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
SEMI MINUTE NINETY M. ON A LARA
MISTER CALDERON MOVES A MISTER
DALI SECONDS AT THE READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS OF
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES
FROM THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
WE ARE MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
I ABSENCES.
ARE.
ALL ABSENCES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND REPORTED IN TODAY'S JOURNAL.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHT TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS EGGMAN AND PATTERSON TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AIKMAN'S GAS WILL BE SEATED IN
THE AREA MEMBERS DESK FOR THE
WOMEN OF THE YEAR CEREMONY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THEIR CRUSH OF
THE GRANTED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER PLEASE THOUGHT REMOVE
THE FOLLOWING BILLS FROM THE
ENACT OUR. MOVE THE FOLLOWING
BILLS TO THE NOT TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN S. B. ONE THIRTY FOUR
ITEM NINETEEN S. B. ONE SIXTEEN
AND TWENTY SQ ONE EIGHTEEN. I'M
TWENTY ONE S. B. ONE TWENTY I'D
TWENTY TWO S. B. ONE TWENTY ONE.
ITEM TWENTY THREE SB FOUR SIXTY
FIVE WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
REQUEST IS GRANTED IN THE CLERK
WILL NOTE.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY TWO POINT TWO I AM RE
REFERRING FILE ITEM TO A. B.
SIXTEEN NINETY FOUR STONE TO THE
HUMAN. SERVICES COMMITTEE.
A GUESS INTRODUCTIONS WILL BE
DONE AFTER THE WOMAN OF THE YEAR
CEREMONY.
WE'RE NOW MOVING TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FORTY
SIX.
ALL BILLS WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
CURRENT AND SENATE AMENDMENTS
FILE TO IS RE REFER TO
COMMITTEE.
A RECONSIDERATION THE MOTIONS
FOR FILE ITEMS THREE THROUGH SIX
OUR CONTINUED.
WILL TAKE A FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
IN A MOMENT.
I WILL PASS AND RETAIN ON THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING SENATE THEIR
READING OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE'RE NOW MOVING TO OUR WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH SO CEREMONY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM FOURTEEN EACH
ARE SEVENTY SIX FOR THE PURPOSE
OF THIRD READING.
THE CLERK WILL READ HR SEVENTY
SIX.
HOUSE RESOLUTION SEVENTY SIX BY
SOME OF OUR EGGMAN AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO WOMEN'S HISTORY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I AM PROUD
TODAY TO PRESENT HR SEVENTY SIX
PROCLAIMING TODAY MARCH IS
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH.
WOMEN ARE NATURAL BORN LEADERS
WE ARE SURROUNDED BY YOU ALL IN
THIS ROOM YOU HAVE LONG BEEN THE
BACKBONE OF OUR FAMILIES OF OUR
COMMUNITIES OF OUR BUSINESS OF
OUR STATE.
I HOWEVER IS RECENTLY AS THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH WASN'T EVEN
CELEBRATED AND IT WASN'T UNTIL
SOMEBODY IN CINEMA COUNTY. THE
HOME OF MY OF MY COLLEAGUE OVER
HERE REPRESENTING THE THE
WINTERS AREA THAT WE REALIZE
THAT WE GET A COMMISSION THAT
CAME FORWARD AND SAID WE NEED TO
BE CELEBRATING THIS.
SO NATIONAL WOMEN'S HISTORY
MONTH THAT WHICH IS NOW
NATIONWIDE AND WORLDWIDE WAS
STARTED RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
SO WE COULD FEEL GOOD ABOUT
THIS.
SO FROM HOBBLING BEGINNINGS WE
HAVE GONE THIS FAR AND ALTHOUGH
THROUGHOUT THE MONTH OF MARCH WE
CELEBRATE THE ACHIEVEMENTS. WE
STRIVE TOWARDS EQUITY AND
HIGHLIGHTS THE WORK OF FAMILIES.
AS WE OPEN THIS AS WE BEGIN TO
CELEBRATE THESE FANTASTIC WOMEN.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON HR
SEVENTY SIX AND ASK FOR THE
FIRST ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
THE CLERK WILL PLEASE OPEN THIS
ROLE FOR COOPER.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR COAL
AUTHORS.
THIS ROLL CALL IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS THIS ROLES FOR COFFERS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING THE VOTES.
THERE ARE SIXTY FOUR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE.
ALL OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE WILL NOW HEAR WELCOMING
REMARKS IN THE ACTING CHAIR OF
THE WOMEN'S CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN
MEMBERS AGAIN IT IS MY PLEASURE
TO STAND BEFORE YOU TODAY. AT
AND AS WE PRESENT A THE WOMAN OF
THE YEAR.
IN THAT FOR FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO HAVE BLAZED
TRAILS YOU HAVE SWORN TO SERVE
AND PROTECT HE WORKED TIRELESSLY
TO PROVE YOUR COMMUNITIES YUBA
THE FRONT LINES IN THE BATTLE
FOR EQUAL RIGHTS YOU REMOVE
BARRIERS. YOU'VE SERVED AS AN
INSPIRATION FOR GENERATIONS TO
COME AND AS WE OFTEN TALK THIS
YEAR ABOUT THIS BEING THE YEAR
OF THE WOMAN I THINK WE ALL NEED
TO EMBRACE THE IDEA THIS IS THE
GENERATION OF THE WOMAN.
AND AS MY MY ESTEEMED COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO TALK ABOUT WOMEN
ARE THE ONES OFTEN THAT ARE
ROCKING THE CRADLE WHEN PEOPLE
ARE BORN. AYE COMES AS A HOSPICE
WORKER AND I CAN TELL YOU AT THE
END OF PEOPLE'S LIVES IS ALSO
WOMEN THERE. ASSURING PEOPLE OUT
ON THE OTHER SIDE AND ROCKING
THAT SAME CRADLE AND WOOD AND
WELCOMING PEOPLE AND ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
THERE'S A PROBLEM TO SAY THAT
WE TALK ABOUT THAT THE YOU YOU
ARE NOT TRULY GONE IN TOLD THE
LAST PERSON DOESN'T REMEMBER YOU
ANYMORE AND SO THE WORK THAT YOU
HAVE DONE. OF MAY WE ALL LIVE
LONG PASS OUR BODIES ARE HERE ON
EARTH AND TO THINK ABOUT THAT AS
WE MOVE FORWARD AND THAT WE
CONTINUE TO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES INSPIRE THE NEXT
GENERATION BREAKDOWN MORE DOORS
WE ALL KNOW THAT DOORS WERE
BROKEN DOWN FOR US. AND IS NOW
OUR RESPONSIBILITY AND OUR
PRIVILEGE
TO CONTINUE TO BREAK DOWN THOSE
DOORS FOR THE NEXT.
WE HAVE THE NEED FOR STRONG
WOMEN THERE IS STRENGTH IN OUR
DIVERSITY WE ARE HERE
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS ALIKE
WE ARE FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WE ARE FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
BUT AT OUR HEARTS WE ARE ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND HAVE SERVED. IN
THIS COMMUNITY IN THIS GREAT
STATE WE HAVE WORKED ON PAY
PARITY WE HAVE WORKED ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WE HAVE WORKED
ON HUMAN TRAFFICKING WE GET
WORKED ON AGRICULTURE. THERE ARE
SO MANY THINGS THAT WE DO WE IN
THE LEGISLATURE ARE INDEBTED TO
YOU LARGE AND SMALL FOR THE WORK
THAT YOU DO WE ARE ABLE TO BE
HERE AND PASSED LAWS IN THIS
BEAUTIFUL CHAMBER YOUR HOUSE.
BUT WITHOUT WHAT YOU DO EVERY
DAY IN YOUR COMMUNITIES WE WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH OR BE
INSPIRED TO CARRY ON THE WORK
THAT WE DO SO ON BEHALF OF ALL
OF US. WE ARE INDEBTED TO ALL OF
YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN MEMBERS
HONOREES
AND GUESS WE'RE NOW GOING TO
BEGIN OUR SPECIAL CEREMONY TO
HONOR OUR WOMEN OF THE YEAR.
KEEPING WITH OUR PREVIOUS
PRACTICES WITH REGARD TO THE
CEREMONY THE NAMES OF THE
HONOREES WILL BE READ IN
DISTRICT ORDER.
AT THIS TIME OF MEMBERS WHO
REPRESENT DISTRICTS ONE THROUGH
TEN.
SHOULD RETIRE TO THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER.
ASSEMBLY A SPEAKER ANTHONY
RENDON ACTING WOMEN'S CAUCUS
SURE SUSAN EGGMAN AND REPUBLICAN
LEADER BRIAN DOLLY WILL PRESENT
THE HONOREES WITH A SPECIALLY
PREPARED CERTIFICATE AFTER
THERE'S A.
ESCORTED BY THEIR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
I WILL ASK SPEAKER RENDON
CHAIRWOMAN EGGMAN TO MOVE TO THE
CENTER AISLES TO RECEIVE OUR
HONOREES.
CLERK WILL BEGIN AS SOON AS
APPROPRIATE TO READ THE NAMES OF
THE HONOREES FOR TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT ONE.
JEANNIE MISTEL ESCORTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOWNEY.
AN AMERICAN IN CALIFORNIA BY
CHOICE JEANNIE MISSILE ARRIVED
IN SHASTA COUNTY IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE
AND PROMPTLY MADE HERSELF A
VITAL MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY.
THROUGH HER DECADES OF
INVOLVEMENT IN BUSINESS YOUTH
PROGRAMS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THE THING THAT REALLY STANDS OUT
IS HER ABILITY TO BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TO JENNY
CHAMBERLAIN ESCORTED BY SOME A
MEMBER WOULD.
JENNY CHAMBERLAIN IS AN
INSPIRING LEADER IN CINEMA
COUNTY'S HISPANIC AND LATINO
COMMUNITY.
SHE IS HIGHLY REGARDED AS A
CHAMPION FOR IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND PROMOTING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUNG LATINO
LEADERS. JENNY IS THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT OF CINEMA COUNTY'S
HISPANIC CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
SECRETARY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
HISPANIC CHAMBER
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THREE
RACHELLE GROSSED ESCORTED BY
FAMILY MEMBER GALLAGHER.
MICHELLE BROKE STARTED AS A
VOLUNTEER WHEN THE BOYS AND
GIRLS CLUBS OF THE NORTH VALLEY
HOPING TWENTY TWO YEARS AGO. NOW
AS THE C. E. O. SHE'S OUR
CHILDREN'S GREATEST CHAMP.
SHE HAS NEVER LOST SIGHT OF THE
ORGANIZATION'S MISSION
AND ENSURES EVERY CHILD HAS A
CHANCE.
THE
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FOR HOLY
COOPER AND AMANDA PEREZ ITS WORD
BY FAMILY MEMBERS AGUIAR CURRY.
HOLLY COOPER HAS EXTENSIVE
LITIGATION EXPERIENCE DEFENDING
THE RIGHTS OF IMMIGRANTS
SERVING AS CO DIRECTOR OF THE
IMMIGRATION LAW CLINIC AT UC
DAVIS.
SHE THE NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
EXPERT ON IMMIGRATION DETENTION
ISSUES AND ON THE IMMIGRATION
CONSEQUENCES OF CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS.
AHMAD DEFERENS BRINGS A WEALTH
OF EXPERIENCE AND EXPERTISE ON
IMMIGRATION AND POPPING LA TO
THE UC DAVIS SCHOOL OF LAW
IMMIGRATION LAW CLINIC WHERE SHE
SERVES AS THE CO DIRECTOR AND
SUPERVISORS LOST STUDENTS AND
PREPARATION OF DEPORTATION
DEFENSE CASES
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT BY LAURIE
FORSTER ESCORTED BY SOME A
MEMBER BIGELOW LAURIE FORSTER A
FIFTH GENERATION RESIDENT OF
AMADOR COUNTY WAS AN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL TEACHER AND CALAVERAS
COUNTY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN SHE
HAS BEEN A MEMBER OF THE AMADORI
COUNTY FAIR BOARD AND HAS BEEN
VERY ACTIVE WITH THE JUNIOR
LIVESTOCK AND MISS AMADOR
SPONSORED PAGEANT COMMITTEES.
SHE THE PAST FOR EACH CLUB SHE
PROJECT LEADER ENJOYS HELPING
THE YOUTH IN AMADOR COUNTY.
SHE LIVES IN AYE ON CALIFORNIA
WITH HER HUSBAND RICHARD ENJOY
SPENDING TIME WITH HER TWO
DAUGHTERS THEIR HUSBANDS AND
THEIR FIVE GRANDCHILDREN. ALL
LIVING WITHIN FIVE MILES OF HER
HOME.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICTS SIX
ROSARIO RODRIGUEZ
ESCORTED BY A FAMILY MEMBER
KILEY. ROSARIO RODRIGUEZ IS THE
OWNER OF SUTTER STREET TAQUERIA.
AN ICON OF THE FULL SOME
RESTAURANT SCENE AND PEOPLE'S
CHOICE FOR BEST BUSINESS OF THE
YEAR. BIZARRO IS ALSO A ROTARIAN
BOARD MEMBER OF THE TWIN LAKES
FOOD BANK AND A BOARD MEMBER FOR
THE FULL SOME CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICTS SEVEN
PEGGY DELGADO FATHER. IS SCORED
BY SOME THE MEMBER MCCARTY.
PEGGY FATHER WORKS TIRELESSLY TO
CREATE A BRIDGE FOR HIGH RISK
YOUTH AND THE YOUTH DETENTION
FACILITYIN SACRAMENTO. AND IS
DEDICATED UPLIFTING MARGINALIZE
YOUTH AND CONNECTING THEM WITH
VITAL SERVICES AND RESOURCES.
HAVING BEEN THROUGH THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM HERSELF PEGGY
FOUNDED THE BRIDGE NETWORK TO
ADDRESS THE SYSTEMIC FAILURES
THAT AFFECT OUR COMMUNITIES
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT EIGHT
MICHELLE BROWN STEVE ESCORTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER ON THE
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLEY.
MICHELLE STEVE IS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF SAINT JOHN SHELTER
FOR REAL CHANGE.
UNDER MICHELLE'S LEADERSHIP ST
JOHN'S HAS TRANSFORMED FROM A
SHELTER INTO A CONTINUUM OF CARE
THAT ADDRESSES THE ROOT CAUSES
OF HOMELESSNESS THROUGH
EDUCATION SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING. MICHELLE
WANTS TO SUCCESSFUL EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE
THE SKILLS NEEDED FOR FORMALLY
HOMELESS WOMEN TO GAIN AND
MAINTAIN EMPLOYMENT.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT NINE
ALICE A HOFFMAN SCORED BY
SOMETHING NUMBER COOPER.
US THEY HAVE MEANT WAS HAS WON
ELECTIONS FOR CALIFORNIA STATE
AND DOUBLE ACP PRESIDENT AND
SERVES ON THE NATIONAL NWC
KEYBOARD.
COORDINATES FIFTY FOUR BRANCHES
INCLUDING SACRAMENTO.
SELECT OR IN HER BLOOD
TIRELESSLY REGISTERING IN
GETTING AFRICAN AMERICANS OUT OF
THOSE. SHE LOVES POLITICS
MENTORING YOUTH AND GROOMING NEW
POLITICAL CANDIDATES
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TEN LUCY
EVER TELL DIAL ESCORTED BY SOME
OF THEIR LEVINE. WHO SEE IT AS A
DIRECTOR OF IMMIGRATION LEGAL
SERVICES ACT NOW ALLIANCES NFL?
SHE HAS HELPED MANY FAMILIES A
TEAM LEGAL STATUS PROTECTED
PEOPLE FROM DEPORTATION AND
EDUCATED THE RENT COMMUNITY
ABOUT THE RIGHTS OF IMMIGRANTS.
JUST BEEN A KEY PLAYER AND NOW
ALLIANCES EFFORTS TO MITIGATE
THE IMPACTS OF THE NATIONAL
POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH
WE LIVE IN
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT ELEVEN
LYNN KIRSTIE ESCORTED BY SOME A
MEMBER FRAZIER. LINGER SKI HAS
MADE A PROFOUND IMPACT ON HER
BRENTWOOD COMMUNITY AS AN
EDUCATOR AND AGRIBUSINESS WOMAN
AND A MEMBER OF NUMEROUS SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS.
SHE IS ALSO THE PROUD MOTHER TWO
SONS AND FIVE GRANDCHILDREN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM FRAZIER IS
PROUD ANNIE LINGER SKI AS THE
ELEVENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT WOMAN
OF THE YEAR
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWELVE.
JODY AS STARS THE OUT ESCORTED
BY SOME A MEMBER FLORA.
BEEN SEEK A POLICE CHIEF JODY
STARS LEO IS THE CITY'S FIRST
FEMALE POLICE CHIEF AND THE ONLY
FEMALE POLICE CHIEF IN THE
TWELFTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. SHE
LIVES IN LONDON WITH HER HUSBAND
JEREMY AND THEIR TWO CHILDREN
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FOURTEEN
MERLE CRAP SUPPORTED BY SOME
REMEMBER RUBIO ON THE BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON.
MORRELL CRAFT IS A LIFELONG
PITTSBURG RESIDENT WHO HAS
WORKED IN VOLUNTEERED WITH THE
COMMUNITY FOR MORE THAN FORTY
SIX YEARS.
SHE LETS HER LIFE BY THE MOTTO.
THERE IS NO GREATER HONOR THAN
TO SERVE.
HER CONTRIBUTIONS TO PITTSBURGH
AND SURROUNDING AREAS CANNOT BE
OVERSTATED
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTEEN
IRMA L. ANDERSON ESCORTED BY
SOME A MEMBER THURMOND.
IRMA L. ANDERSON HAS BEEN A
CIVIC AND COMMUNITY LEADER IN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY FOR DECADES.
IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO SHE
SERVED AS THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMAN ON THE RICHMOND
CITY COUNCIL AND IN TWO THOUSAND
ONE SHE WAS ELECTED THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN MAYOR OF
A MAJOR CITY IN CALIFORNIA.
BEFORE ENTERING POLITICS SHE WAS
THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSING AND CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIXTEEN
CHARLENE'S EGGMAN SCORED BY
SELLING NUMBER BAKER. TRAILING
SEGMENT EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATOR
AND SPEECH SPEECH LANGUAGE
PATHOLOGISTS START THE NONPROFIT
SCHOOL OF IMAGINATION HAPPY
TALKERS AND TWENTY FIFTEEN HER
PROGRAM BECAME THE REGION'S ONLY
INCLUSION CENTER. BASED ON THE
EARLY START DENVER MODEL A TIME
MAGAZINE TOP TEN MEDICAL
BREAKTHROUGH FOR THE TREATMENT
OF AUTISM.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVENTEEN
AUTOMATICALLY WHO ESCORTED BY
SOMETHING MEMBER DAVID CHIU.
AUTOMATICALLY WHO IS CURRENTLY
THE SENIOR DIRECTOR OF STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR
PIZZA.
SHE SERVES AS PRESIDENT OF THE
BOARD FOR THE WE SAID ENOUGH
FOUNDATION.
IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TIME MAGAZINE RECOGNIZED ITEMIZE
OF SILENCE BREAKER IN FEATURED
ON THE COVER OF THEIR PEOPLE OF
THE YEAR EDITION
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT EIGHTEEN
THE HONORABLE LEAH BELLA
ESCORTED BY SOME OF OUR BONTA.
LEAH BELLA IS BEING RECOGNIZED
FOR HER CONTRIBUTIONS EMPOWERING
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS.
SHE SERVES AS A MEMBER OF THE
ALAMEDA CITY COUNCIL AND HOLD
THE POSITION OF VICE MAYOR.
SHE DILIGENTLY WORKS TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS AND NEEDS OF
ALAMEDA
IMPROVING QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
FUTURE GENERATIONS
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT NINETEEN
JOHN GRAF ESCORTED BY SOMETHING
MEMBER TEAM.
FOR THIRTY SEVEN YEARS JOAN
CRAFT HASN'T SERVED AS PRESIDENT
OF LEGAL AID AT WORK.
HER CAREER IS DEDICATED TO
ADVANCING THE CIVIL RIGHTS OF
WORKING POOR PEOPLE THOSE
TOILING IN THE SHADOWS TO MAKE
THE WHEELS OF OUR ECONOMY TURN.
MISS CRAFT IS HONORED TO RECEIVE
THIS RECOGNITION AT A TIME WHEN
COURAGEOUS WOMEN ARE SPEAKING
OUT AND WOMEN ARE RAISING
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY
CHERYL BOYKINS ESCORTED BY
FAMILY MEMBER REYES ON THE
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK.
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY EAST
BAY POLICE CHIEF DARRYL BLAKE
AND A FORMER HAYWARD POLICE
DEPARTMENT COMMANDER HAS A
PROVEN LEADERSHIP RECORD OF
PROMOTING COMMUNITY POLICING
THAT BUILDING PARTNERSHIPS AND
COMMUNITY TRUST IN HAYWARD. HER
MOTTO IS. I WANT TO SEE PEOPLE.
I WANT PEOPLE TO SEE THE
DEPARTMENT HAS ONE OF US AND NOT
ONE OF THEM
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY
ONE REPRESENTING HER MOTHER
LILLIAN ROBERTS IS CONNIE
ROBERTS ESCORTED BY SOME A
MEMBER GRAY.
LILLIAN ROBERTS OF MERCED HAS
BEEN A LOCAL LEADER IN THE AREAS
OF EDUCATION AND CIVIL RIGHTS
FOR HALF CENTURY A MORE.
SHE WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
ACCOMPLISHING THE DESEGREGATION
OF SCHOOLS AND PERCENT COUNTY
SERVING AS THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN TEACHER AT A SCHOOL IN
NORTH MERCED.
LILLIAN HAS BEEN A MENTOR FOR
THE COMMUNITY AND THE ASSEMBLY
TWENTY FIRST DISTRICT IS HONOR
TO RECOGNIZE HER TODAY.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY
THREE DEBORAH RASH ESCORT BASED
ON THE NUMBER PATTERSON.
DEBORAH RUSH IS THE CO FOUNDER
AND C. E. O. OF BREAKING THE
CHAINS A NONPROFIT THAT WORKS
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT TO RESCUE
RESTORE AND SHELTER FEMALE
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
DEBORAH IS ALSO A SURVIVOR OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING SHE'S MADE IT
HER MISSION TO HELP OTHERS FIND
THE COURAGE AND STRENGTH TO
BREAK FREE
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY
FOUR LOUIS SAID WADA ESCORTED BY
SOME REMEMBER BERMAN. WE SIMPLY
WHAT IT IS THE LONG TIME C. E.
O. OF THE GRIEVANCE WHAT FAMILY
HEALTH CLINIC IN EAST PALO ALSO.
SHE OPENED HER FIRST COMMUNITY
HEALTH CLINIC FOR MIGRANT FARM
WORKERS IN NINETEEN EIGHTY IN
SALINAS.
SINCE THEN SHE'S DEDICATED HER
LIFE TO PROVIDING HIGH QUALITY
MEDICAL CARE TO AT RISK AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY
FIVE SHARON YUSHAN YANG ESCORTED
BY FAMILY MEMBER KANSEN CHU.
SHARON YOU SUNDAY AS A PARA
EDUCATOR FOR SANTA CLARA COUNTY
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
COMMISSIONER OF SU CHI
FOUNDATION SHARON'S MESSAGE IS.
LET US PRAY FOR PEACE IN OUR
LAND KEEP OUR HEARTS FROM
SORROWS AND PAINS. BLESS US ALL
WITH JOY AND HOPE. LOVING CARE
FOR EACH OTHER IN THE WORLD
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY
SIX SHARON ALISON KRAUSS.
ESCORTED BY SOME A MEMBER
MATHIS.
SHARON ALISON CRACK IS CURRENTLY
THE DIRECTOR OF MARKETING AND
PROGRAMS AND THERE CAN VETERANS
DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA AND A
NOTARY PUBLIC.
CHOOSE CHOSEN AS WOMAN OF THE
YEAR DUE TO HER HARD WORK AND
DEDICATION TO HELPING THE
CITIZENS OF TULARE COUNTY.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY
SEVEN THERESA CUTS DOWN ON US
ESCORTED BY FAMILY MEMBER KALRA.
THERESA BECAUSE DIANA'S HAS BEEN
INFLUENTIAL IN IMPROVING THE
QUALITY OF LIFE AND IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES.
SHE IS A DEVOTED MOTHER
GRANDMOTHER AND GODMOTHER ALL
THE WHILE SERVING HER COMMUNITY
THROUGH ADVOCACY FOR THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY OFFICES EMIGRATE
RELATIONS.
AND SERVING AS AN ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVE FOR SAN JOSE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THAT
YOUR AD
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY
CELESTE WALKER ESCORTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW.
SELECT WALKER IS A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER CANCER SURVIVOR WIFE
AND MOTHER. SHE SERVES THE CITY
OF CAMPBELL AS A PARKS AND
RECREATION COMMISSIONER AND SHE
OWNS AND OPERATES SNAKE AND
BUTTERFLY CHOCOLATE FACTORY.
CELESTE CO FOUNDED THE ORCHARD
CITY CHAPTER OF INDIVISIBLE A
NATIONWIDE GRASSROOTS MOVEMENT
TO RESIST THE TRUMP AGENDA
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY
NINE LUIS BURNER ESCORTED BASED
ON THE NUMBERS DOWN.
LOUIS PARTNER A RETIRED PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE'S VOLUNTEERS AT THE
INFORMAL CASE WORKER FOR ELDERLY
WOMEN FIFTY HOMELESS THAT.
SHE FOUNDED THE FREMONT STREET
MISSION FOR ELDERLY WOMEN TO
HELP THINK THIS UNDERSERVED IN
VULNERABLE GROUP TO HOUSING
RESOURCES AND EMPLOYMENT.
MATCHING THEM WITH JOBS AND
IMPROVING SAFETY AND WELL BEING
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY
LAURIE KOSTER ESCORTED BY SOME A
MEMBER CABALLERO. LAURIE KOSTER
IS THE FORMER CHAIR AND C. E. O.
OF MAN PACKING COMPANY. THE
PRODUCER OF FRESH VEGETABLES
HEADQUARTERED IN CALIFORNIA
SALINAS VALLEY SHE CURRENTLY
CONSULTS AND THE AG BUSINESS
SECTOR. SHE IS A GRADUATE OF CAL
STATE CHICO AND RESIDES IN
SALINAS WITH HER HUSBAND AND TWO
BOYS JACK AND SAM
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY
ONE BIRTH THE DOWDY SMACK.
ESCORTED BY A FAMILY MEMBER
AROUND LAST. DOROTHY DADI SMITH
IS A LIFELONG FRESNO RESIDENT
WHO ATTENDED LOCAL SCHOOLS FROM
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH COLLEGE.
A GRADUATE OF CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY FRESNO DADI RETIRED
AS A KEY THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATOR
AFTER THIRTY SEVEN YEARS.
DODD HAS SERVED ON LOCAL STATE
AND NATIONAL BOARDS TASK FORCES
AND AS A VOLUNTEER FROM MANY
DIFFERENT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS
HER PROUDEST ACCOMPLISHMENT
ACCOMPLISHMENT IS HAVING RAISED
HER TWINS TO BECOME SUCCESSFUL
ADULTS WHO VALUE EDUCATION AND
THE PRINCE OF PUBLIC SERVICE.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY
TOO SURELY WEGMAN ESCORTED BY
SUMMING AMBER SOLACE
SURELY WEGMAN INTO THOUSAND ONE
BECAME THE CITY OF LOS GOES
FIRST FEMALE MAYOR. AND I SERVED
ON THE CITY COUNCIL SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
SHE'S PROVEN HERSELF TO BE A
RELIABLE SELFLESS AND DILIGENT
MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY WITH
CONTINUOUS DEDICATION TO THE
PEOPLE OF KERN COUNTY AND THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY
THREE LANA TOMLIN ESCORTED BY
SOME A MEMBER OBERNOLTE.
LANA TOMLIN WAS RECENTLY
PROMOTED TO ASSISTANT SHERIFF OF
SUPPORT FOR THE SALMON ENCINO
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
SHE'LL OVERSEE THE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS AND LEGISLATIVE LIAISON
LIEUTENANT.
THE CORRECTIONS BUREAU COURT
SECURITY CRIME LAB THE CORONER.
PLAY RESOURCES THE SHERIFF'S
ACADEMY PUBLIC AFFAIRS AND LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT LEGISLATIVE
EFFORTS.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY
FOUR LEVINE JARROW SCORED BY
SOME REMEMBER PHAM THE LUNCH
AREA IS THE LEAD KITCHEN
SUPERVISOR AT THE MISSION AT
KERN COUNTY. A HOMELESS FACILITY
IN THE THIRTY FOURTH DISTRICT
SINCE TWO THOUSAND WHEN SHE HAS
BEEN IN CHARGE OF MAKING SURE
MEALS GET PREPARED THREE TIMES A
DAY. THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FIVE DAYS A YEAR AND AS EITHER
PREPARED OR SEEM TO THE
PREPARATION OF MORE THAN TWO
POINT THREE MILLION MEALS SINCE
YOU STARTED WORKING AT THE
MISSION.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY
FIVE SURELY SUMMERS ESCORTED BY
A FAMILY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM.
SURELY SUMMERS ASSISTED SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTIES MENTALLY ILL
POPULATION FOR OVER TWO DECADES
THROUGH HER WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND CORRECTION.
SHE IS ALSO AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF
THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN AND VOLUNTEERS
ON COUNTY WAY COMMISSIONS ON
AGING AND LEGAL ADVOCACY
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY
SIX KARINA JURIES ESCORTED BY
SOMETHING MEMBER LACKEY.
GREEN ENTRIES IS THE CD  AND
GENERAL MANAGER OF MOJAVE AIR
AND SPACE PART.
SHE OVERSEES ALL TESTING
OPERATIONS AT THE AIRPORT AND
MANAGES REGIONAL PARTNERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT.
JEEZ LEAVES THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF STRATEGIC INITIATIVES FOR THE
BENEFIT THE COMPANIES OPERATING
IN THE MOJAVE AND I'VE BEEN
WORKING TIRELESSLY TO BUILD UP
THE REGION.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY
SEVEN TRACY LAIR SCORED BY
FAMILY MEMBER LIMON.
TRACY LAIR AS A REPORTER AND
ANCHOR FOR K. E. RIGHTS HE IN
SANTA BARBARA AND VENTURA
COUNTIES.
SHE IS ON THE SCENE WHEN THE
THOMAS FIRE BROKE OUT VENTURA
COUNTY AND AGAIN WHEN MATSUSHITA
WITH STRUCK BY DEVASTATING
FLOODS.
AT A TIME WHEN THE MEDIA'S UNDER
ATTACK TRACY'S COMMITTED TO
ENSURING HER COMMUNITY AS WELL
FIRMS
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY
EIGHT JUDY PAN MEN ESCORTED BY
SOME A MEMBER ACOSTA.
JUDY MOVE TO SANTA CLARITA FOR
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS AND
IMMEDIATELY BECAME INVOLVED IN A
WIDE VARIETY OF CAN
THE SERVICE ACTIVITIES IN THE
VALLEY.
LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS RANGING FROM
EIGHT IS THE LIKE THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION TO ZONTA.
HAVE BENEFITTED FROM HER ENERGY
ENTHUSIASM AND PASSION FOR
SERVICE
SHE HAS SERVED IN LEADERSHIP
ROLES FOR COUNTLESS
ORGANIZATIONS AROUND THE SANTA
CLARITA VALLEY AND BEYOND.
HER MANY HOURS OF SERVICE HAS
TRANSLATED INTO RAISING
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS FOR HER
COMMUNITY.
SHE OFTEN SAYS THAT SHE WAS BY
THE HELEN KELLER QUOTES
ALONE WE CAN DO SO LITTLE
TOGETHER WE CAN DO SO MUCH.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FORTY
MAYOR OCWEN AT A WARNING
ESCORTED BY SOME MEMBERS
STEINORTH.
I WANTED A WARRANT WAS ELECTED
AS FONTANA'S FIRST FEMALE AND
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN MAYOR
DECEMBER TWENTY TEN.
MAYOR WARRANT HAS FOCUSED HER
TENURE ON IMPROVING PUBLIC
SAFETY BRINGING BUSINESS TO THE
CITY GENERATING JOBS CREATING
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AND
ADVOCATING FOR A HEALTHIER
COMMUNITY. IN MAYOR WARNS WORDS
FONTANA IS ALWAYS OPEN FOR
BUSINESS AND INCREASING JOBS.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FORTY ONE
RIENECK THAT'S BEEN ESCORTED BY
SOME A MEMBER HOLDEN. DOCTOR
COULD BEST MAN IS A VERY
ACCOMPLISHED POSITION OF
INTEGRATIVE MEDICINE AND A CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER FROM SOUTH
PASADENA.
SHE IS COMMITTED TO ANSWER
GRADING LAND USE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION. AND IN THIS NAY
POLICY TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
AND ENVIRONMENT.
IN HER PRACTICES INTEGRATIVE
MEDICINE SHE DRESSES
ENVIRONMENTAL AND GENETIC RISK
FACTORS FOR THE PREVENTION AND
TREATMENT OF DISEASES
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FORTY TWO
LIMBO BALL THE ESCORTED BASED ON
THE NUMBER MAYES.
LINDBERG ALL THE A CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT FOR OVER FIFTY SEVEN
YEARS AS A COMPASSIONATE ACTIVE
LEADER AND THE SAN GORGONIO PASS
REGION. ENGAGING WITH MANY
ORGANIZATIONS SHE'S AN ADVOCATE
FOR THE DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
SUPPORTS VETERANS AND ACTIVE
MILITARY AND IS A LEADER IN
PROVIDING HEALTH SERVICES
EDUCATION BUSINESS LEADERSHIP
AND PHILANTHROPY.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FORTY
THREE JANET DEAL SCORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN.
JANET HAS RAISED HER FIVE
CHILDREN AND VOLUNTEERED IN THE
BERKELEY COMMUNITY FOR FORTY
YEARS.
SHE HAS A DISTRICT WIDE
REPUTATION AS A PROLIFIC A
TIRELESS BONDS HERE AS AN
ADVOCATE FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND A LEADER AND
PHILANTHROPIC IT'S IF IT CAUSES.
JANET BELIEVES PASSIONATELY THAT
ADVENTURE GET BACK TO THEIR
COMMUNITY
.
FROM A FAMILY DISTRICT FORTY
FOUR JILL LETTER ESCORTED BY
SOME THE NUMBER IRWIN.
JILL LETTER IS THE PRESIDENT AND
C. E. O. OF THE GREATER KANEKO
VALLEY CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
SERVING THE CITY'S AT THOUSAND
OAKS WESTLAKE VILLAGE IN A GREAT
HELL'S. THE GREATER CANNELLA
VALLEY CHAMBER IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST IN THE WESTERN UNITED
STATES AND HOLDS THE ELITE FIVE
STAR RATING FROM THE U. S.
CHAMBER
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FORTY
SEVEN DIANA RODRIGUEZ SCORED BY
SEPTEMBER REYES.
AS PRESIDENT OF SAMBOR MEDINA OH
VALLEY COLLEGE DIANA RODRIGUEZ
OVERSEES A DIVERSE CAMPUS AT
FOURTEEN THOUSAND STUDENTS AND
THE HEART OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA'S INLAND EMPIRE.
DEANNA IS A CARING LEADER BUT
THE TRACK RECORD OF IMPROVING
CAMPUS MORALE PIECING ENROLLMENT
ADVOCATING FOR INNOVATION AND
SPECIAL DEVELOPMENT. AND
SUPPORTS OVERALL STUDENT SUCCESS
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FORTY
EIGHT WANNA* SCORED A BASE A
MEMBER RUBIO.
ONE I'M NOT THAT IMMIGRATED TO
THE U. S. AT THE AGE OF TWELVE
AND CURRENTLY LIVES IN THE CITY
OF LOVE WEDNESDAY.
SHE WORKS FULL TIME AS A SOCIAL
WORKER FOR THE DEPARTMENT
CHILDREN AND FAMILY SERVICES
WHERE SHE PROVIDE SUPPORT
COUNSELING RESOURCES AND
ADVOCACY TO CHILDREN VOTE BEEN
APPEARS
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FORTY
NINE ELOISE ESCORTED BY SOME
REMEMBER CHAU.
STILL ONLY AS THE SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT AT THE WHITE THE
COMPANY LIMITED AND PRESIDENT AT
THE WHITE THE MOTORS
INCORPORATED.
STELLA OVERSEES THE DAY TO DAY
OPERATIONS AND LONG TERM
STRATEGIC PLANNING FOR BE WAIT
THESE NORTH AMERICAN AND LATIN
AMERICAN OPERATIONS.
UNDER STYLE OF LEADERSHIP THE
WHITE DE HAS ACHIEVED
EXPONENTIAL MARKET GROWTH
BECOMING A GLOBAL FORCING CLEAN
TECHNOLOGY AND CONSUMER
ELECTRONICS.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY
KAREN STEWART ESCORTED BY SOME A
MEMBER BLOOM.
FOR MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE YEARS
KAREN STEWART HAS SHATTERED
GLASS CEILINGS THROUGH HER
REPRESENTATION OF ARTISTS IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY. AND HER
EFFORTS TO HELP ELIMINATE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IN THE WORKPLACE.
SHE CURRENTLY SERVES AS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF TALENT AGENTS
WHICH LEAD OVER A HUNDRED AND
FORTY TALENT AGENCIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY ONE
THE TCO GUEVARA ESCORTED BY
SOMETHING MEMBER CARILLO. IT HE
SAID WELL LARA AS A RESIDENT OF
THE EL SERENO COMMUNITY IN LOS
ANGELES
SHE'S AN ACTIVIST ON BEHALF OF
MEN AND WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION.
THROUGH HER NINETEEN YEARS AT
LABORERS LOCAL THREE HUNDRED.
DURING A TIME WHEN MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES ARE BEING ATTACKED
IT HE SAID REMAINS THE STAUNCH
ADVOCATE OF WORKING CLASS PEOPLE
BY LEADING VARIOUS CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT ACTIVITIES THROUGHOUT
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY ONE.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY TO
REAL MARIA ALONSO SCORED BY SOME
IN THE RODRIGUEZ.
MARIA ALONSO MIGRATED TO THE U.
S. FROM MEXICO AS A MOTHER AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER IN ONTARIO.
MARIA HAS DEDICATED HER LIFE TO
BETTERING THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF OTHERS
SHE FOUND IT WORDS AT A VALUE A.
AN URBAN FARM THAT GIVES
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ACCESS
TO FRESH FRUITS AND VEGETABLES
MARIA IS A TESTAMENT TO WHAT IT
MEANS TO PLACE COMMUNITY FIRST
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY
THREE BLAIR BASTIN ESCORTED BY
SOME A MEMBER SANTIAGO.
BLAIR VESTED HAS BEEN THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
HISTORIC RECORD BUSINESS
IMPROVEMENT DISTRICT IN DOWNTOWN
LA KINGS TWENTY ELEVEN.
WORKING AROUND SKID ROW HAS
INSPIRED BLAIR TO BECOME A
PASSIONATE ADVOCATE FOR THE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS AND
MENTALLY ILL WHILE CONTINUING TO
PROVIDE A SAFE COMMUNITY FOR
RESIDENTS BUSINESSES AND
VISITORS
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY
FIVE WENDY DO ESCORTED BY SOME A
MEMBER CHEN.
WENDY DO IS A LEGAL ENTREPRENEUR
WHO FOUNDED A BOUTIQUE LAW FIRM
THAT SERVES THE WELFARE OF SMALL
BUSINESSES AND PROMOTES
COMPLIANCE OF LABOR LAWS.
SHE IS A FORCING BOSTROM
POLITICAL AWARENESS AND AS A
LIAISON BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND THE ASIAN COMMUNITY.
JEFF LET'S SEXUAL HARASSMENT
PREVENTION SEMINARS FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS AND IS A PIONEER OF
THE NEED TO MOVEMENT.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY SIX
LUCY MORENO ITS WORD BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES ON THE
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA.
LUCY MARINO WORKS FOR CLINIC ES
DE SALUTE THE PUEBLO AS A
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT PROGRAM
MANAGER SHE'S DEDICATED TO
PROVIDING QUALITY HEALTHCARE
SERVICES TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FIFTY SIX.
AND IS WELL KNOWN FOR LEADERSHIP
IN ORGANIZING THE FLYING DOCTORS
HEALTH AND RESOURCE FAIR
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FIFTY
NINE BOBBY JEAN ANDERSON
ESCORTED BY SOME A MEMBER JONES
SAWYER.
BOBBY JEAN HAS BEEN A TRUE ASSET
AND LEADER TO THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES WITH OVER FORTY YEARS OF
PUBLIC SERVICE.
DURING HER TWENTY FIVE YEARS
WITH THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE SHE LED SEVERAL
SUCCESSFUL PILOT PROGRAMS THAT
WORK ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
PRISON REFORM. AS WELL AS MANY
OTHER COMMUNITY ADVOCACY ISSUES
.
FROM A JUST SEEK A TIME ESCORT
BASED
ON THE MEMBER SURVIVED SAYS.
JESSIE IS SEPARATE COMMUNITY IN
VARIOUS POSITIONS THEIR HER ROLE
AS THE HEALTHIER GROUP BUT
VALLEY DIRECTOR AND BOARD MEMBER
UNDER YOUR ROOF BAY AREA
RECREATIONAL PARKS DISTRICT.
HER EXCEPTIONAL LEADERSHIP
QUALITIES COMBINED WITH HER
DESIRE TO SERVE OUR COMMUNITY IS
INSPIRATIONAL
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIXTY ONE
ESTHER PRETTY ORGANS ALLAH'S
I SCORED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MEDINA.
ESTHER PRETTY OKAY DOLLARS AS A
LIFELONG CHAMPION FOR SOCIAL
CHANGE WRITING TO IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES.
SHE BELIEVES THIS CAN BE DONE BY
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING
COALITION BUILDING AND ADVOCACY.
ESTHER IS SIZE IN RIVERSIDE WITH
HER HUSBAND AND TWO CHILDREN
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIXTY TWO
LINDA LACKS.
SORT OF ESCORTED BY SOME MEMBER
BURKE.
LINDA LOTS OF IS A LIFETIME
DEMOCRAT WHO'S LIVED IN THE
VENISON DEL REY NEIGHBORHOOD.
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY ELECTED
AS A DELEGATE FOR EIGHTY SIX TWO
TWICE LINDA WAS PREVIOUSLY
ELECTED PRESIDENT OF THE VENICE
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL FOR TWO
TERMS.
CURRENTLY LINDA WORKS FOR THE
VENICE COMMITTEE HOUSING A
NONPROFIT HOUSING DEVELOPER
PROVIDING PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING TO OVER FIVE HUNDRED LOW
INCOME
PEOPLE.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIXTY
FOUR RAMONA PENANCE HOLLIS
ESCORTED BY THREE MEMBER GETS
IN.
A FORTY YEAR RESIDENT OF CARSON
REMINDED HIM AND SALAS A PROUD
MOTHER GRANDMOTHER GREAT
GRANDMOTHER. AND IS CELEBRATING
HER FORTIETH WEDDING ANNIVERSARY
THIS YEAR.
SHE IS A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
AND IS KNOWN AS ONE OF THE MAJOR
VOLUNTEERS FOR THE CITY OF
CARSON.
RAMONA ALSO CURRENTLY SERVES AS
VICE CHAIR OF THE CARSON
PLANNING COMMISSION
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIXTY
FIVE JOANNA ZUBA ESCORTED BY
FAMILY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
JOANNA TSUBA AND HER HUSBAND
HOWARD HOW LIVE IN FULLERTON FOR
THE PAST TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND
HAVE TWO CHILDREN.
JOANNE HAS BEEN A VERY ACTIVE
MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY
SUPPORTING MANY LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING.
THE NATIONAL CHARITY LEAGUE
SAINT JUDE HOSPITAL CRITTENTON
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES PATHWAYS OF HOPE AND A
FULL OF TEN YMCA
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIXTY SIX
EIGHTY HOMER ESCORTED BY SOME
REMEMBER MERCY G..
ANYHOW WHERE THAT SERVES AS
MAYOR AND MANHATTAN BEACH
A FORMER SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER AN
ENVIRONMENTAL ACTIVIST
SHE'S INVOLVED IN MANY NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY. FRIENDSHIP CIRCLE
AMIGOS ELUDED US AND SOUTH
DAYCARES. MAYOR HOW WORTHLESS
THE ORIGINAL PHOTO EDITOR FOR
WIRED MAGAZINE AND IS A LIFELONG
GIRL SCOUT.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIXTY
EIGHT ARIANNA BARRIOS ESCORTED
BASICALLY MEMBER CHOI. ARIANNA
VARIOUS IS OWNER OF
COMMUNICATIONS LIVE IN THE CITY
OF ORANGE
SHE ACTIVELY VOLUNTEERS FOR THE
LATINO LEADERSHIP ACADEMY MARIAN
BERGESON FOUNDATION CW AL A. AND
CALIFORNIA WOMEN LEAD AND SMALL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT CENTERS.
MARIO SERVES ON THE COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION OF ORANGE AND AS A
TRUSTEE FOR THE RANCHO SANTIAGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVENTY
ONE DANA STEVENS ESCORTED BY
FAMILY MEMBER VOEPEL.
DINA HAS DEDICATED HER ADULT
LIFE TO THE SERVICE AT COMMUNITY
CHEST THAT TWENTY PLUS YEARS
ADVOCATING FOR COMMUNITIES UP
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES FIRST.
COMMUNITY ACTION SERVICE AND
ADVOCACY BELIEVES THAT POVERTY
SOCIAL ISOLATION ACCESS TO
QUALITY EDUCATIONAL AND
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES.
ARE CRUCIAL TO RAISING YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO CONTRIBUTE TO SOCIETY
AND EMBRACED SOBRIETY
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVENTY
FOUR TINA ANDERSON ESCORTED BY
FAMILY MEMBER HARPER.
TINA ANDERSON IS CURRENTLY THE
PRESIDENT OF THE TO ELEVEN
MARINE ADOPTION COMMITTEE IN
IRVINE.
AND ACERBIC COMMITTEE SINCE ITS
INCEPTION IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVEN FROM BABY SITTING AT A
VERY YOUNG AGE TO WORKING AS A
NANNY FOR MILITARY FAMILIES.
TINA HAS A STORIED HISTORY OF
SERVING OTHERS.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVENTY
FIVE CATALINA CICCONE.
ESCORTED BY SOME THE NUMBER
WALDRON COUNCILMAN CATALINA
CICCONE HAS BEEN ELECTED BY THE
PITCHER ON THE PEOPLE TO SERVE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND SIX.
CATALINA WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW TRIBAL
IDENTIFICATION THAT'S BEEN
RECOGNIZED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
CATALINAHAS HELPED RAISE MORE
THAN FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR THE SUSAN G. KOMEN
INLAND EMPIRE.
A GUIDING PRINCIPLE FOR CATALINA
ITS IMPORTANCE OF COMMUNITY AND
WORKING TOGETHER. A SINGLE
MOTHER FOR CATALINA RESIDES IN
TO MAKE YOU LAUGH.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVENTY
SIX ROBBIE COLTRANE HAAS
IT'S GOING TO BUY SOME AMBER
CHAVEZ. ROBBIE CALDERON COSTS IS
BROKER AND OWNER OF HAAS TEAM
REALTY. HER DEDICATION AND
PASSION IS BASED ON THE BELIEF
THAT OUR YOUTH IS THE FUTURE.
THIS IS LETTER TO HOLD MANY
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS IN MANY
CITIES.
ROBBIE HAS RAISED FUNDS FOR
EDUCATIONAL SCHOLARSHIPS LOCAL
SPORTS CHILDREN'S THEATER FUNDS
FOR SUMMER CAMP. AND SHE
PROVIDES ONE ON ONE MENTORING OF
YOUNG GIRLS.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVENTY
SEVEN CHERYL SHAW ESCORTED BASED
ON THE NUMBER MAIENSCHEIN.
I LIKE LONG SAN DIEGO AND MR
SHAH HAD A LONG AND SUCCESSFUL
CAREER IN ESCROW INDUSTRY.
SHE AND HER HUSBAND MIKE HAVE
TWO CHILDREN AND FIVE
GRANDCHILDREN ALL OF THEM AND
SAN DIEGO.
CHERYL IS AN ACTIVE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER AND PLAYED A PIVOTAL
ROLE IN HELPING HER NEIGHBORS
REBUILD AFTER THE TWO THOUSAND
AND THREE CEDAR FIRE. AND THE
TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN WHICH
CREEK FIRE.
CURRENTLY SERVING AS CHAIR OF
THE SCRIPTS RANCH CIVIC
ASSOCIATION NEIGHBORHOOD WATCH
SHALL KEEP YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD
SAFE AND WELL CONNECTED. SHE IS
A WELL RESPECTED COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER AND MANY SAN DIEGANS
ARE GRATEFUL FOR HER SERVICE.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVENTY
EIGHT ANTI KOREAN ESCORTED BY
SOME AMBER GLORIA.
ZANTAC FOR AND HAS BEEN FIGHTING
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE IN SAN DIEGO SINCE LONG
BEFORE IT WAS TRENDY.
SHE FOUNDED THE ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH COALITION IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY AND HAS BEEN A CONSTANT
CHAMPION FOR THE EMPOWERMENT OF
HEALTHY AND SUSTAINABLE QUALITY
OF LIFE FOR THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SEVENTY
NINE DEBORAH MAXI ESCORTED BY
SOMETHING MEMBER WEBER.
DEBORAH MAXI IS A CHICAGO NATIVE
AND MOVE TO SAN DIEGO IN THE
LATE NINETEEN SEVENTY.
DEBORAH WORKED TIRELESSLY AS AN
EDUCATOR FOR FORTY FOUR YEARS
BEFORE RETIRING AS VICE
PRINCIPAL IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
DEBORAH ENJOY SPENDING TIME WITH
HER FAMILY AND FRIENDS AND
CURRENTLY SERVES ON THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT EIGHTY
I'LL HAUNT US AVAIL US A LEASE
ESCORTED BY SOMEONE NUMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN GONZALEZ FLETCHER
PROBABLY RECOGNIZES NATIONAL
CITY COUNCILMAN FELLOW HUNTERS
THAT THEY LOS ELISE AS A TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WOMAN OF THE YEAR. FOR
YEARS COUNCILMAN SO THEY LISTEN
LEASE HAS FOUGHT HARD FOR
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES LOCAL SCHOOLS
SMALL BUSINESSES ENVIRONMENTS
LIKE TRANSPORTATION JUSTICE AND
MORE.
SHE'S AN ACTIVE MENTOR AND ROLE
MODEL FOR WRITING YOUNG LATINAS
.
THE FOLLOWING HONOREES WERE
UNABLE TO ATTEND TODAY.
CATHERINE CURRY WILLIAMS FROM
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FORTY SIX.
SANDRA HOWDEN FROM ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FIFTY SEVEN.
TOMORROW COOLEY SIMO FROM
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIXTY SEVEN.
RIA RUSSELL LOPEZ FROM ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT SIXTY NINE.
MICHELLE GRUBS FROM ASSEMBLY
DISTRICTS THAT IN THE.
AND JEAN TO ENGINE FROM ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT SEVENTY THREE.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTEEN.
KATHY TAKAHASHI.
ESCORTED BY SEVEN NUMBER EGGMAN.
KATHY'S PASSION FOR HELPING
CHILDREN HAS HELPED EXPAND THE
BULLDOG PROJECT THROUGHOUT HER
COMMUNITY IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY.
CREATED BY HER SON THE BULLDOG
PROJECT IS AN ANTI BULLYING AN
ANTI VIOLENCE PROGRAM
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE SCHOOLS AND
AWARENESS TO STUDENTS ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES OF BOWLING
CYBERBULLYING DRUGS ALCOHOL
GAINES. SEXUAL ASSAULT IN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING
.
FROM ASSEMBLY DISTRICT MARY
FRANCE.
ESCORTED BY SPEAKER ANTHONY
RENDON.
MAMA RANTS AND CAN USUALLY BE
FOUND ATTENDING PARENT WORKSHOPS
AND SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS
A SINGLE MOTHER OF FOUR
GRANDMOTHER OF SIX AND GREAT
GRANDMOTHER FOR. MAMA IS
PRESIDENT AND FOUNDER OF THE
DISTRICT AFRICAN AMERICAN
ADVISORY PAY PARENT COUNCIL
WHICH PROVIDES RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT TO AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS IN THAT WAY
CONGRATULATIONS AND GRATITUDE TO
ALL OF OUR HONOREES.
MEMBERS ON YOUR
MEMBERS ON YOUR DESK THERE IS A
MOMENTO OF TODAY'S EVENT
THE BIOGRAPHIES OF ALL OF OUR
HONOREES ARE IN A BOUND BOOKLET.
ON BEHALF OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS SOMEONE THANK EVERYBODY
WHO PARTICIPATED ALL OF THE
GUESTS AND FAMILY MEMBERS THAT
ARE IN OUR GALLERY TODAY.
THIS CONCLUDES OUR CEREMONY BUT
PLEASE REMAIN SEATED AS WE
CONTINUE SESSION.
WE'RE NOW MOVING TO GAS
INTRODUCTIONS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK AMEND SPEAKER OUT.
EXCUSE ME WHILE I GET MY GLASSES
ON.
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF
THE AVIATION CAUCUS.
I'D LIKE TO A JOIN IN WELCOMING
OUR GUESTS FOR THE AVIATION AND
AEROSPACE DAY.
AVIATION AND CALIFORNIA PROVIDES
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE POINT
SEVEN BILLION AND IMPACT ON OUR
ECONOMY AS WELL AS OVER. ONE
POINT ONE MILLION JOBS. A
GENERAL AVIATION ALONE CREATES
AN ECONOMIC IMPACT OF THIRTY.
A POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS A
GENERAL AVIATION. AND AEROSPACE
IS OUR. HOME TO CALIFORNIA WITH
MANY MANY JOBS ARE HOME TO
TWENTY TWO MILITARY AIRFIELD SIX
HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR STATE
PERMITTED AVIATION FACILITIES.
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT FAA
REGISTERED AIRCRAFT. AND FIFTY
NINE THOUSAND EIGHT CERTIFIED
PILOTS.
A AEROSPACE PLAYS A POWERFUL
ROLE IN CALIFORNIA ECONOMY
DIRECTLY EMPLOYING MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED AND THREE THOUSAND
PEOPLE SUPPORTING MORE THAN.
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND JOBS
RELATED IN FIELDS RESULTING IN
TWO POINT NINE BILLION IN ANNUAL
STATE INCOME REVENUES. IT IS A
GREAT DEAL OF UP. A JOY THAT
TODAY OUT WE HAVE SCOTT MALTA.
I HE IS THE HERE A AS THE
PRESIDENT AND OF THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA AIRPORTS AND HE IS
HERE TO S.. B. RECOGNIZED INTO
ACCEPTED NUMBER MEMBER
RESOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF THE
AVIATION AND AEROSPACE
INDUSTRIES THANK YOU FOR
WELCOMING OUR GUESTS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I ALSO
WANT TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FRESNO AS CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
SELECT COMMITTEE AND TAKEN OFF
THE AEROSPACE AND AVIATION DAYS.
THERE IN THE STATE CAPITAL WE'RE
ALL PROUD OF CALIFORNIA BEING GO
GLOBAL LEADERS AND INNOVATION.
IN THE AEROSPACE INDUSTRY AND SO
I WANT TO JOIN. MY COLLEAGUE AND
WELCOMING ALL OF OUR GUESTS IN
THE. AEROSPACE INDUSTRY
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY OR
RECOGNIZE FROM.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON STATUS.
THANK YOU MAN IS BIGGER AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO WELCOME THE
ZETAS UP IN THE GALLERY THEY ARE
FROM THE ZETA PHI BETA SORORITY.
AND ANNOUNCED ORGANIZATION
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN TWENTY.
THEY HAVE OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND MEMBERS WORLDWIDE
FOCUSED ON THE WELL BEING OF
WOMEN AND CHILDREN PUMP
CAL EQUITY IN THE UPLIFTMENT OF
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA OUR NATION THE
HERE TODAY IT'S TALK TO
LEGISLATORS ABOUT OUR PRIORITIES
IN THEIR PRIORS AS WELL THAT'S
PLEASE GIVE THEM A HAND AGAIN
THANK YOU.
MOVING ON TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
MEMBERS THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION.
HEARING IS RESCHEDULE FOR FOUR
PM TODAY IN ROME FORTY TWO OH
TWO. AND A VERY IMPORTANT
ANNOUNCEMENT IT IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUDY SOLACE IS BIRTH DATE
TODAY. WHAT'S WHICH I'M HAPPY
BURKE I.
THIS PERSON SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS TUESDAY MARCH
THIRTEENTH.
WEDNESDAY.
XIN THURSDAY MARCH FIFTEENTH
FLOOR SESSION AT NINE A. M..
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED
TANE ALL MOTIONS SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING IN HERE THERE
NOTE HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO.
BOB SORRY WE HAVE ONE MORE LATE
BREAKING ANNOUNCEMENT.
I WAS JUST TOLD THAT IS ALSO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEYS BIRTHDAY
TODAY.
AND WITH THAT MISTER CALDERON
MOVES AND MISTER DALLI SECONDS
THAT THE HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY MARCH FIFTEENTH
AT NINE.
A QUORUM CALL WAS LIFTED